right away you want to open up with
something ridiculous you know you want
to turn the F listen we got on here we
got on graveyard we're
good are you calling someone hi honey
everything
good all right I'm going deep in the
murky water so all right is it cold out
there is it cold out there yes it is
indeed cold out here but we did really
we're doing well all right and my
[__]
there uh your
J he's here all right send him my
love
bye that's it oh Tik
Tock rubber I thought it was
hallucinating because you said I'm
putting it on airplane mode and then a
phone started ringing no no no no I
called my wife just to before I put on
airplane mode you know I'm a
professional dog I I figured it out I
just I figured it out I know you
did every every week you call me and
it's half an hour earlier I have to take
the edible pretty soon it's going to be
9: in the morning taking the you're like
this we I had a rough morning so I had
to come home and take a nap before the
edible I got up I washed my muffler I
made a protein shake and I threw three
of them down and I just threw another
one down with a [__] Snapple iced
tea that's it I haven't had dinner yet
so it's perfect when I get out of here I
have a little [__] something
something you know what I'm saying
that's the best part I love I I love
doing on an empty stomach and then and
then like it's a great and like I do you
time out at all you probably don't like
you look at your face you don't you're
really irritating me you know what I'm
saying time out I think a timeout
believe it or not if I told you this
man I can't eat these no more during the
week wow because I find myself like
destroying food
like bag dripping and [__] like in the
morning whether it's uh you know [__]
salad a protein shake whether it's
sometimes I eat those Honey Nut Cheerios
I kill that box that little skinny
[__] Co box they used to be big boxes
all of a sudden [__] coid came and
the boxes [__] shrunk and some that
to me well that's what I was talking
about like I time out my Edibles to eat
like I don't want it to hit
after you need to train you're like a
half a [__] like a break like I take it
in order to eat migrs there's no 60
milligrams in our world we start at 200
here so get it together listen can you
can you give me like can you give me the
benefit of the doubt and tell these
people when I took 60 the first time in
like years is when I was driving back
from a a show it was driving back I
don't want to drive an hour on 200
where's he going I gotta get my
Snapp
walk
away the [__] what's happened you
savages the checken is brought to you by
freeze pipe happy Halloween listen stop
looking like a [__] when you're getting
stoned all right if you're tired of
breathing in harsh smoke and then
coughing up a half a lung you got to try
freeze pipe it's an awesome device that
cools down the Smoke by over 300 Dees so
you can take icy cool hair
all night long like a doctor you pop the
glycerin chamber in the freezer for an
hour to get started hour and a half as
the smoke passes through the chamber bam
it's cooled off no afterburn no coughing
I love it I made a video yesterday on
Instagram with the new freeze pipe I
busted out I had the other one for like
two years but it was time to go bigger
so listen check out their newest pieces
the mini bang and the tornado bong I
really love it it's a tight little bun
you can hide it under your car it's an
awesome way to get an icy cold hit every
time let me break it down for you this
company's American-owned for seven years
and affordability price shop the
smoothest and coolest pipe bubblers
bongs at more at the free pipe.com use
code Diaz Diaz for 10% off your entire
order that's freeze pipe.com code Diaz
for 10% of your entire order remember
one thing this makes a great Christmas
present trust me what I'm telling you
even Grandma I love it the checkin is
also brought to you by bluechew it's
Halloween it's a beautiful night to
sling dick with your little [__]
crazy outfit on you're GNA have an
incredible evening tonight but don't
ruin it with crappy sex blue chew is
here to make sure things stay up and up
you know what I'm saying even if you
have a wolf man suit on it's tied around
the waist blue Chu is an online service
that delivers Ed meds straight to your
door with the same active ingredients is
Viagra
Calis Levitra and you're getting all the
fun at a fraction of the cost all right
just sign up at blu.com consult with one
of their meic medical providers and once
you're approved bam you get the
prescription in just a few days it's
totally online so nobody knows nothing
you don't have to go to some doctor's
office and they look at you like a
vampire and you don't got to think like
your dick is broken hide behind the veil
of the internet and perk things up from
the comfort of your couch listen this is
the real deal you pop one of these blue
Cho like 30 minutes before you want to
get down forget about it you'll be
sniffing a little panty liner you follow
me blue Chu wants to help you have
better sex discover your options at
bluechew.com chew it and do it Jack and
as a special deal for the check and
listeners try blue Chu free what are you
talking about Joey free when you use
promo code Joey at checkout just pay $5
for shipping that's blu.com promo code
Joey to receive your first month free
visit blu.com for more details Lee where
you at turn off your TVs run for your
lives it's over they didn't put you on
this planet just give up if Uncle Joey
could do it I can rule the world
actually you got to be thinking welcome
back
[Music]
to happy Tuesday you Savages Uncle Joey
here with the [__] flying JW Lee
Sayad I shouldn't even say that because
now they'll chase him in an airport you
know what I'm saying Lee's gonna start
getting chased like [__] OJ theeven
through airports that [__] I was talking
to somebody they said did you see what
happened in Russia I don't know anyway
it's good to see everybody what's up Ley
Leland I'm doing really good I hope I
don't get [__] chased I can't comedy
this last week really fun I did
um
it's starting to heal but now it's dry
so I got to put cream in my [__] ear
with a Q-tip now the whole day it feels
like there's sperm in my [__] ear
just so I don't know what's what me I
got like Donald Duck in my left ear
please I got
problems 60 years old everything starts
falling apart who has a yeast infection
in their [__] ear you know what I'm
saying why you putting do you think it
could be from putting your your glasses
in your ear it could be a lot of things
sometimes I put my pinky in my ass and
put it in my ear you know something's
going to [__] happen a pumpkin a
[__] piece of corn something but
anyway I'm good but it was really it was
really it was really good I got I was
really happy I had a couple cool things
happened but it was that this one show I
did and I did the longest I've ever done
I did like 39 minutes and that's oh [__]
crazy for me which is really cool
everything what' you say you didn't call
C I love the message all right don't
call you
back but um it was really cool like a
bunch of people came out from the
podcast it was like like this one guy
said he walked three miles like from the
he was at like Worcester State and it
was just really
cool I I offered he said he he got an
Uber I
offer um but it was just really cool
because I've had a bunch of like not
like Terri terrible sets but a bunch of
like stuff I was wasn't super happy with
and the whole I did basically every joke
that I
do and I was it was able to like flow
and it was a pretty I thought I did
pretty well there was like 30 people
there was pretty [__] said you do
last
week um let's
see I need this number quickly five this
number should be a little number you
should have a little like you know like
Geeks have that little pen thing where
they put their pens in there you have to
have one in your shirt with how much
money you got in the bank at that time
and how many you did last week and what
your goal is on set for next
week you know your bank changes every
hour on the hour I know you got millions
of dollars under the mattress but you
got all these Investments so a guy like
you has got to be on top of everything
so every hour you got to call the bank
Lisa at-
9991 give me the account number but Mr
you just called last listen I'm calling
every day on the hour every [__] hour
however you want to figure it out that's
it shit's changing there's a war Saudi
Arabia gasoline you know things are
happening in [__] uh you know
everywhere I'm really H sorry about but
you know what I knew that dude shot him
I knew that dude in main shot himself I
told my wife the people they looking for
a [__] ghost you know he shot himself
he [__] he ate some mushrooms and
went into the weeds and said [__] it
it's over baboom I ain't got I'm done
where you gonna go you gon to go to
Canada and deal with the mounties you
know I [__] who you are even Rambo got
shot a few times this guy didn't look
like Rambo he had you know the [__]
going on but anyway my heart goes out to
the people in New
Hampshire leave the [__] house
because there's a lunatic in your
[__] neighborhood It Felt Like Us
during Co that's what I kept thinking
about this feels like me during Co I'm
sitting here waiting for [__] some
guy to jump through my window with a
black lives matter hat on and a [__]
ready to shoot me and [__] to
death anyway
you no thank you oh my God I'm fck I
can't breathe what's the problem
everything you not the problem it was
funny you it was not good it was not
good last week my heart goes out to that
you know there was a time when you
didn't watch [__] like that you don't
pay attention to [__] like that but now
since it's everywhere it's all over you
you gotta [__] you gotta read a
little bit and see what's going on you
know I don't believe nobody anymore you
know first they said he shot 40 people
then it went down to 22 then it went
down to 18 you know and I know in the
beginning the the numbers aren't
accurate but my heart goes out there
that that place don't deserve a [__]
lunatic like that no but they got those
people it's like when I I was thinking
about when I first went to Colorado when
I was 19 I met [__] dudes out there
that eventually they were going to shoot
somebody like with an AR there was a lot
of Vietnam bets when I got the Aspen and
I really thought about it after I left I
really got tight with two of them I got
tight with two Vietnam bets one in
basal or where did he live yeah he lived
in basal close to Aspen and then when I
moved to Boulder I met a guy and I was
friends with him till the dad got in
that car and
left and he he like how how did they
remind you of the mass
shooter listen you could tell that they
were a little unstable you know they had
to go to the VA they were on medication
some of them had agent orange and they
had issues they were too young when they
got shipped over
there and the Vietnam guys really saw
some [__] wild [__] you know I listen
I wasn't there I was a young kid like I
was in CU yeah I wasn't there but you
know I talk to this guy a
lot and none of none of those Vietnam
dudes I never did cocaine with why they
weed and they drank you know they didn't
do Coke like that and and they told me
about what happened they would tell me
little things you know you see a lot man
that's traumatic 18 I don't care how
they train you you know the mind is the
mind you know so you know it's it's
interesting you say it though cuz my
like my mom is still she watches the
news like three times a day and it was
on right before we started and CBS News
was doing a story about how like there's
a statist they see a trend of people who
do mass shootings there's a trend of
like a certain percentage of them have a
military background and they were like
it was I couldn't believe they had it on
the news because that's gonna piss off
everybody but then
B like it I can't imagine going through
like being a soldier I can't imagine
like I
every day like I I I'm amazed more
people don't have like panic attacks and
freak out like it it doesn't make it
doesn't surprise me that like people who
go through that terrible [__] have
issues that we don't do like anything
about which is crazy but you know when
you see something traumatic right when
you you're walking in New York City and
some guy on a bike gets hit by a car you
know you giggle you walk a little
bit you know no helmet on so it's not
going to be a good [__] thing you're
not going to see that every day unless
you're in the city every day your
percentages are higher that one of these
bike guys in the city gets hit by a
truck or something you know it it
happens but that's one day that I saw
that let's say I saw his head blow up
let's say I saw building land on him or
whatever that's one day and that could
do a lot of damage to you my heart goes
if you ever witnessed that in any level
but to see it every
day for a year or six months to live
under that pressure you know and then to
get out of it it's it's a big it's like
you got a [__] air tank and it's
filled and you're like deflated and you
don't know where that balloon's gonna
land you know so that's a crazy way to
describe never heard it describe like
that but you know like I said I really
was interested in those guys all three
of those guys that I became friends with
I really thought the world up one guy
used to sleep at his house on Friday
nights and I would hang out with him i'
smoked dope with his wife we'd watch
movies you know we talk about weapons he
took me to shoot you know so it was
always uh I when I
skied when I first got up there the guy
who owned the Mason company was also a
Vietnam vet but he was like a good-look
blond haad guy you know he was all right
he was a ski Champion like he had won
something you know and he was back home
he was originally from the area but he
seemed normal he was running a business
and that you know Hey
listen that's
uh that's a good little percentage there
you
know
it's so yeah I wanted to speaking of
news uh Joe could you pull up that clip
I saw something and I wanted to get your
reaction to it here we go
I know because every because we were
talking about your rules every you're
like you're in my head with everything
but especially with food and I saw this
guy he is going to raise your blood
pressure Angeles in Los Angeles if you
order a bagel you walk in you say hey
can I get a scoop gluten-free Bagel the
person behind the bar is usually like of
course we have these different options
today for gluten-free of course I can do
that for you in New York I just walked
in and asked for a sco gluten-free Bagel
guy just looks at me he goes I'm not
scooping your [__] bagel bro I like
dude that's how I wanted it's like get
the [__] out of here with that [__] I
was like all right on to the next one I
guess there's nothing more so that's it
like what do you know what a scooped
Bagel
is I have no [__] idea it's when they
go in like you ask them to
like yeah there you go my wife made
pasta ful for lunch with like triple
garlic in it I've been farting knocking
myself out I'm must have passed out
three times this afternoon from the
garlic oh Jesus Christ was even in my
sleep atne a mask it got in what it made
an into sleep Happ mask yeah I took a
nap this afternoon so when I woke up I'm
like what the [__] is this garlic smell
in this mask I had a soaking Listerine
and brush my teeth and take a shower get
that garlic effect out of me but anyway
why are we talking about garlic here
what are you a vegetarian what else is
going on kakua some dude who ate a scoop
and a bagel listen man man what can I
tell you I don't know I don't know I
don't know these people I don't know
what they're talking about a scoop and a
b I'm an old man I go get a bagel maybe
once a week sometimes I put that hot
jalapeno spread on it a little turkey a
little swiss cheese a tomato stop
it that's it so but you don't ask them
to scoop the inance of the bagel out
like the no no I never take the middle
out if you anybody takes the middle out
I take it out of Italian bread rip it
out of there and then put a stick of
butter on that [__] and put it
down like a little Super Bowl with the
butter in the middle and I just pop that
[__] that's how you eat bread
the guts people used to tell me when I
was a kid I was going to get sick when I
got older from meeting all the guts of
the bread but I don't give a [__] this
guy's not eating it he's taking it and
throwing it away I know what are you
gonna do these people are muks why do
you even bother me with these
people well when I lived in that lane
you'd go in and say let me get a
gluten-free [__] bagel let me tell
you something am I own a place in the
Bronx and you come in and ask me for a
gluten-free Bagel like I'm at this age I
just got like a [__] torture chamber
downstairs why because I'm gonna put
everybody who [__] with me I'll put
them downstairs like uh like that
Hannibal what's that movie Silence of
the land he used to yeah tie up the
chubby chicks in the basement and [__]
and give them cream to rub on them and
stuff I put every anybody who comes in
with a goofy [__] can I get goats
milk in the coffee sure
I got a goat downstairs let's go see it
you can milk it here bring your kid too
you [__] goat milk god that's what I
thought I can't stand [__] goats milk
no I had a I had a good weekend I did a
bunch of uh like stuff with my
girlfriend's kids like we did the
pumpkin maze [__] and carve
pumpkins that's great yeah I I I I've
never liked I like Halloween for like
the the candy like I've never like I've
never done like like the
adult Halloween party thing do you I
can't imagine when was the last time you
dressed up does mercy make you dress up
are you [__] crazy I don't
know party and there were three dads
last night that look like [__] Jack
offs I just sat there going what the
[__] why do I do this to myself I put on
like New York Cuban shirt on that was my
Halloween costume I wanted as say Ruben
The Swinging Cuban all right
it's for the
IM that's
it but you look at that you know me I
don't know I have no sense of humor when
it comes to that I was never a Big C
listen on Halloween you know what I did
I'm coming over I don't no pennies I
don't want no Tootsie Rolls I want a
dollar bill we're gonna have a [__]
problem right me and two of my buddies
are coming up we need
dollars I don't want no apples I don't
want no candy
you know but that candy comes in handy
except for one night when I eat like
[__] 12200 milligrams and I go
upstairs and I bump into one of those
candy bags and I can't those baby roots
and the [__] every night I destroy
something different I take all the baby
Roots out then the next week I take out
all the [__] M&M's then the next week
I take all the Swedish Fish the Reese's
pumpkins are the things to get me those
Reese's pumpkins are [__]
dangerous you know but now over the
years it's it's slowed down but when I
have
Edibles I can't control the sweets
upstairs my wife we got a box of [__]
chocolate from uh you know from Mercy's
softball team to sell these kids don't
know how to sell Dick okay at that age I
was selling them stealing them back
reselling them [__] taking the
insides out you
know but these kids don't even I even
told I go we have to take those up to a
restaurant and sell them she's like no
dad what the [__] these kids have no
idea how to [__] sell I'll get her
I'll get her trust me so what did you
end up buying all the chocolate bars
yeah my wife hit him upstairs but you
know me f [__] uh you know I'm a fat
[__] look at this Bugle on my face I
could sniff out ODS that you've never
seen before so I found them and they had
almond bars up there I was eating two of
the
sharly oh like three nights I Mo them I
told my wife you got to get those out of
the [__] house enough is enough you
know I'm down there [__] light myself
on fire with the bum I up there's got to
be something going on you know what I'm
saying yeah that's you need live in a
dangerous area like have we told them
about chocolate bread yet about who I I
don't about chocolate bread the Royal
Crown chocolate bread holy [__] and the
last batch I got was the best batch I've
ever had in my life I don't know what it
was I did I ate that whole thing in one
sitting I left the elbow and I got got
up in the middle of night and destroyed
the [__] elbow last time I told her
don't bring that [__] over here no more
and she's not going to listen N I won't
trust me I gotta go CLE this is the
season I gotta go clean now this is the
season you [__] around now it's January
and you're [__] 60 pounds heavy I
will you know where I live yeah you know
and thank God what bring over in your
neighb what's that what do they bring
over in your neighborhood
now what do you mean what do they bring
over
like because like you know in La you got
tamales like what do what do your
friends bring to your house do you have
people do that now still
poito Kito is a Puerto Rican uh nutmeg
like a uh whatever the [__] that what's
that drink that people drink with Brum
eggn oh okay okay right coconut based
little thing with rum in it you get
[__] up and I got a bunch of Puerto
Ricans at the Jitsu school so there's
two guys that sell it $10 a bottle and
there's a Puerto Rican guy that just
makes it for for me and you I drink like
one bottle with ice cubes you dope it up
with some Malibu or something like that
it does nothing to you but at least you
drink the [__] nutmeg whatever the
[__] it is the eggn I like eggnog I'm
not an an eggnog I drink one six ounce
glass every Christmas and that's
it why why is that do you get like have
you gotten [__] up on eggnog that [__]
they'll find you dead and buried you
start drinking listen if you want to put
weight on if you're a [__]
skeleton you start drinking that [__]
every night and lifting weights five
sets of six squat deadlift behind the
neck front of the necks bench press and
bent over rows that's it do those basic
exercises and eat a steak shrimp you
know salads apples but at night blast
off with a [__] eggnog you see what
happens to you you get big man you get
big [__] yoke you up like a
[__] Jesus and you used to tell
me to get chocolate milk after I do the
the Kettlebell guy I milk just a little
something because they said that at the
at the end of the workout you know
people drink electrolytes but then
somebody was saying that milk ain't bad
so I listen I'm a fat [__] I don't know
what I'm talking about I'm just trying
my I'm saying I had a good month working
out though this month this is my best
yeah and this is my best month since
like June you know July I got a little
[__] up with my back and the whole
lung issue in
August September I was halfway there but
I I kept working out with weights the
whole time through except for the week I
went down to North Carolina and then I
came back and I had to breathe my first
when I go to the gym the first 10
minutes I wanted to [__] shoot myself
why because I couldn't breathe I'd do
the bicycle for 25 minutes you know hit
on the bicycle and then I'd start
stretching out and then I'd start doing
waights the first 10 minutes were brutal
but I go if I could push you these 10
minutes I'll be fine and I kept going
going going I started going back to
Jiu-Jitsu and that's changed me that's
made between this Jiu-Jitsu steady you
know I got a steady thing now I uh I'm
good I'm very happy and very good I'm
I'm good what's your schedule every week
with
it what do you mean like is it Jiu-Jitsu
Tuesday weit it's like what do you what
does a normal week look like for you s
to
it Wednesday off and I stick to it
Wednesday I get lost I go run my big
errands if I gotta go to Newark if I
gotta go to Union City if I gotta go to
Cliffside of North Buran if I gotta go
to Fort Lee that's what I do on
Wednesdays I get the [__] out of here so
I don't go to the gym I get tempted then
Thursday I'll I'll lift this time and
then Friday I go to Jiu-Jitsu and switch
it around
and that's it I burn a certain amount of
calories at Jiu-Jitsu on Monday and then
Friday I do whatever the [__] needs to
be done I just stay there till I get
sore because if I go all out on Monday I
won't make it back till like [__]
Sunday and I can't have that I have to
be more consistent so hey man what I'm
doing the best I can brother because you
have you have to maintain some type of
schedule somewhere or you lose your
[__] mind
you know you got to maintain some
schedule somewhere and for a long time
people would call me for something and
they go all right we have to do it at
12:30 and I go [__] I can't go to
Jiu-Jitsu now so I stop that you know
whatever you could do at 12:30 you could
do at
2:30 I'll be home by 1:30 I'll wash my
monkey get a [__] protein shake and
I'll go wherever you need to meet but
12:30 is out of the question I don't do
that many lunches no more I stopped that
[__] so it's good I'm very I'm in a good
[__] spot and something else happened
in my house this week's this has been
going
down this has been going down for about
two years you know but it really came to
life when we moved to this house because
I would keep my
bong under the
bar and I grinder under the bar it was
hidden but the weed is very
pungent yes it is every time people
would come
down you could smell it sometimes my
wife goes you could smell it in the
[__] hway when you walk in about
three weeks ago I took the bong and I
steamed cleaned it with the steamer hot
water I boiled it my wife she you
smoking pot in the house the whole house
smells because the bong was [__] deep
in THC and I steamed that [__]
so a couple days ago I'm talking to my
wife maybe two weeks ago she says to me
Joey you know the cops were at school
and they talked to Mercy about
marijuana wait wait specifically Mercy
or just her class no no the whole class
you know it was like the dead program a
certain top which I listen you gotta
have that I had that growing up not that
it made a
difference be honest
here not that it made a difference I'm
not proud of that but that's the way it
worked out and I told her you know and
then she
came back and I said so I heard they
talk to you at uh at school about drugs
today she's like yeah Dad marijuana and
then she just started rattling off like
she absorbed the whole
conversation and she was talking about
how this THC you know like little things
it does this to you Dad it does this to
you I go
okay about a week
later I come in and I go she goes dad
are we going to go eat something I go
absolutely and I go go change your hair
and get a jacket and I'll wash my hands
and we'll leave well I went outside to
sneak a bong hit and I'm sitting there
with the bong in my [__] hand and she
comes goes Dad I'm ready she saw the
[__] bong guys she saw the [__] so I
hid the bong I went in I washed my hands
and I made believe it didn't happen we
had a great time anyway I didn't bring
it up but the whole night I felt weird
and I felt like you
know I gotta come clean with her at some
point I got to come clean with her about
things I just had to wait for her to
understand you know she's still too
young for a lot of
things uh so she saw the bong and we
[__] footed around and then one night
she comes into the office when I moved
it and my grinder was on the table when
the lid had fallen off it and she looked
at
it so now I got to say something to her
so I didn't say nothing to my wife I
waited a couple days and she came
downstairs to do something and I called
her over and I go pull up a chair I I
gotta tell you a [__] story oh who
shot
that and
uh and uh you know I go listen when I
was uh 13 I was raised this particular
way
I knew what drugs were and I knew the
evils of
them but one day Mercy I just couldn't
take it and I didn't like alcohol and my
friends were smoking pot and it was it
made me feel terrible I took that
[__] joint I took a hit off it and I
go my world changed M I go I didn't have
anxiety no more but I was very ashamed
of it for two or three years for two or
three years I was very ashamed to
smoking pot I did it with certain people
I I I put cologne on I gargled with
[__] Listerine a little bottle Baka
you know I did the whole thing and then
my mother died I didn't give a [__]
anymore everybody smokes pot you know it
wasn't a big [__] deal so I told her
the truth I said you know I started
smoking blah blah blah and
then I came a couple years ago I did
this and I joined with a company and
that's what laughing gas is also she
sees laughing gas and she sees the joint
tubes and she's not
stupid she's not stupid you know she
doesn't know what's in there but she
never really asked now when I was
growing up I lived in that same
predicament I know they were doing
something and then I found out what
people were doing and then when people
would talk about it in front of me I had
to make believe like I didn't know what
they were talking about but in fact I
knew more about drugs than they were
talking about but I wasn't allowed to
say nothing and that always created like
this conflict with me like this inner
[__] conflict you know I because
you like you had a conflict because you
knew it and like you like you didn't
tell your mom like what was a
conflict the conflict was I saw people
at my mother's bar doing coke I didn't
have the heart to tell other kids it was
1975 I was [__]
12 you know I would see them put the
coke rocks and then I would wake up in
the middle of the night and they'd be my
living room putting Coke shcks in their
nose with the aluminum fall wide open I
would go into the living room and talk
to them but I would make believe I
didn't look at the aluminum
for at one point they stopped putting it
away and at one point you know it was
just an uncomfortable position but I
knew how to it was it put a it [__]
with me a little bit as a child that you
know what I'm saying like I knew
something that nobody else had a secret
about that here's my living room I'm
waking up in the [__] seventh grade
and my mom is is cooking and there's
[__] my stepfather's watching TV and
there's three gorillas drinking [__]
snort and Coke in my living room listen
the Cuban music something ain't right
here you know but it was very hard to
come clean with people at that age and
go what are you talking about I just
left [__] three junkies in my living
room right and it's like you're like
your living room now couldn't be more
different like Mercy doesn't have that
at all no so this house is peaceful
there's nobody showing up here stabbed
in the middle of the night and I gotta
you know clean his hands with gasoline
because he shot somebody and you know
this my life isn't even close to that
this is a [__] we watch Venom at
night you know the cringe whatever the
[__] it is you know I don't want that in
my house especially for her so I [__]
uh told her I told her what laughing gas
was I explained to her that I made a
living that it was medical
marijuana and it helped help people that
we donate to a couple [__] uh PTSD
places you
know and I just didn't want her to live
with that I told her don't say nothing
to your mom and I asked her mom today if
she said something to her she goes no
she hasn't mentioned it to me so we're
straight I feel a lot [__] better now
and next I got to drop another bomb on
her and then I'm G have to drop another
bomb on because she understands but she
really doesn't
like think I'd be talking to you about
this 20 [__] years ago no what am I
doing here but I just want to let people
know that it was a tough decision for me
it was really [__]
tough I pulled it off and I feel better
for doing it I'm not lying to
him well I I think a lot of people and I
I have a I'm not a parent but I think a
lot I hear a lot of parents talking
about like when you make that decision
to like tell someone about that and like
I think like the medicine thing is like
was it just the fact that she saw it
were you just going to wait for her to
see it like what was what made you make
that decision I was going to tell her
eventually she was GNA smell it she's
not
dumb all right let me tell you a quick
one so this little boy that comes over
here I love him with all my heart he
comes over to watch
football he comes over sits here I give
him a yooo we watch the game then he
goes home his little sister comes over
also but one day I passed the joint to
the mom and she left her in her car and
the next day the kid came in the car and
he goes M it smells like Joey's house in
here and she told me she goes g clean up
your house so this was part of the
reason to get rid of the bar the the
children area now is completely [__]
clean I got the bongs outside I got them
locked up so whatever bong I want to use
I go over I broke out a new one from
freeze pipe like one minut they me a
while ago I also [__] raffled off two
of them at the book signing in Brick New
Jersey if you attended it was a [__]
great event everybody was cool as [__]
my nieces came my dear childhood friends
came Frankie Eda showed up I owe him a
call maybe can jump on his podcast
pretty soon and it was just a nice night
you know too bad I can't do like I'm
having a hard time getting them when you
call these places they [__] uh talk
to you like Jimmy bum beam so I'm done
you know unless they come up with a new
Bond and Noble in the area I've called
all of them 914 I've called all of them
you know Manhattan people like come to
the city but there's another place in
the city and they said they were going
to get me in there
and so you know I can't fight with
people no more I'm at an age now I don't
want to yell at agents any of that [__]
I just want to [__] uh do the podcast
work out eat good and be a [__] dead
and smoke reefer I got [__] up this
weekend too oh you did oh you know I'm
cool during the week I'm very cool
during the week but you know what on
Friday it's Miller time so I opened up a
three gr cookie from [__] sillies I
think I had a oatmeal raisin bam ate
that and then Midway somewhere else I
popped another half a bar lordy I was on
[__] fire you understand Friday night
I was seeing [__] I was hearing
[__] and then Saturday I cooled it down
a little bit because I knew Sunday was
going to be a big day and then Sunday I
actually shot a video for them for siles
and as I was shooting it I was eating it
oh damn shooting the video I
realized I ate a b you think about you
didn't think about eating like a fake
bar for the for the video
like that you know me dog there's no
fakes in my [__] world I can't be
selling people a fake you gota do what
you got to do you gotta [__] take one
for the team how are you gonna How You
Gonna sell something if you're not
[__] inhaling this goddamn thing you
know what I'm saying so I went deep into
the murky Waters by the time the [__]
Jets came on I was like [__] you know
that's the only game that was on over
here I don't have the NFL package and I
was too high to drive to jimmies just to
watch the [__] game I was out of it I
was out of it I I watched that jet Giant
game and I went into a [__] coma the
only thing that was keeping me alive was
I put a small [__] 25 on Dallas and
they were blowing out the [__] Rams
at home that's the only bet I put in
that's it I [__] went deep on the
Lord's day so when I went into a little
nap a little [__] uh
mushroom uh whatever you call like a
coma a trance oh trance and I came out
my wife's like we got to go to a
Halloween party what do you think I did
I [__] ate another half a bar and I
went to the Halloween party and I was on
[__] fire I got home at 7:30 last
night on fire I watched two episodes of
The
Killing I watched something else I
didn't even eat nothing the [__] Jes
mushrooms were burning a hole in my
[__] heart I loved them for you
[__] remember always some of
the best [__]
sillies go to Fun Factory Farms
Instagram use my code Uncle Joey Savage
capitals all right whatever what do you
call upper case
uppercat
you I actually had that you are I had
that written down what do you cuz like I
took the edible early and I started
getting a little bit of like paranoia I
started getting nervous for some reason
and I was thinking like because you talk
about like being like you like being
nervous and when you're [__] like what's
your advice to someone to like calm it
down like how do you like go like keep
from losing it go in the bathroom and
throw cold water in your face that's it
and if you really Panic get an ice bag
and put it on your
neck and if it really goes sour take
that same ice bag and put it between
your legs on your balls if that don't
calm you down then jump off the building
because it ain't gonna get no
better that iced bag to the balls might
set [__] off also it might hit some
arous areas and make you go [__]
crazy
and next thing you know you're [__] a
mule down the road I'm I don't know what
are you asking me these stupid questions
for the first thing I do when I got into
a jam that time at the San Jose impra
right chicken
sandwich that slows it down if you eat a
lot of Edibles and
CBD CBD helps know if you're [__] out
on an edible and it's really taking you
down and your heart's beating and on
your [__] whoop watch it's like
[__]
128 I can't have you call in the
hospital like a half a [__] fruit
cake I can't have you do this [__] so
what you do is you put some CBD under
your tongue just basic CBD all CBD for
it to work has to have a lot little bit
of THC there's not gonna be enough in
there to put you over a [__] excuse
me put you over a I just have one of
those Tac burps from the capsules when
they're
fresh I love that I love that [__] that
means it blew up in your chest
tremendous it's probably going into my
[__] lung right now working it Lee
you know what I'm saying walk at it time
is it here who the [__] knows anyway so
yeah that's that's my story and stuff
but you you're slipping lately you're
not in training well I do and
dry I'm over here fck holding up the
fort eating silly three days in a row
tomorrow I got to get up early go to the
gym and then from there I'm going to the
red light therapy to sweat all this
maluka juice out I'm gonna throw all the
small 20 to [__] raise it up to about
35 40 minutes I'm GNA sit in there when
I get out of there my balls are going to
be when I go into the [__] red light
therapy at one point like at the 28
minute Mark I just always cut my balls
and it's like jellies coming out of it
it feels like wav it's like this thick
paste so I don't know what do you do
with
it I drink it what do I
do I put the towel on top of it what do
you think I put in the container we [__]
collagen and drink it like [__] M
theore I don't know what you do with it
you go every week and you check for it
yeah what you do is you go in there and
you pissing a cup when you're in there
so you don't have to leave and then you
drink that in the in the red light
therapy a small 25 if you do it you know
what I'm saying wait you peeing a cup at
the red light therapy it's a joke Lee
it's a f when was the last time I peed
in the cup and now word from my sponsors
hey the checking is here and let me tell
you who I'm going to talk about today
DraftKings on Halloween life doesn't
have to be boring shake things up with
DraftKings DraftKings is the official
sports betting partner of the N
DraftKings an official sports betting
partner of the NBA has an amazing offer
for you to keep things exciting new
customers you're going to score 200
instantly in bonus bets for throwing
down just $5 on the NBA did you hear
what I'm saying they're going to give
you 200 in bonus bets you can make a lot
of dough with $200 get off the couch
even if you lose it doesn't matter
you're still starting the season off
with an instant dub you can even string
together bets from same game or build
your parlay across multiple games let me
tell you what DraftKings did last week
to introduce me to the NBA they threw me
a a free $10 bet did I win no but it
doesn't matter the intention was well
off why because DraftKings cares so
basket basketball is going to be more
fun when you're in on the action listen
you have to pick a a game you could pick
that dude Damien Lillard to score over
30 points the whole season how many
times he's gonna think he's gonna do it
you're gonna be in the green no matter
what so download the draftking
Sportsbook app now and pressing code
Joey new customers get 200 in bonus bets
instantly for betting just $5 only at
draftking Sportsbook with coones J OE y
with
DraftKings the crown is yours now if you
got a gambling problem we got to take
care of this call 1800 Gambler or visit
www.1 1800 gambler. net in New York call
8778 Hope New York but if you ain't got
no problems download the draftking
sports book app and let's get this party
started all right I love you stay black
back to the show we're back Savages I
got to fix my eyeballs they're not
straight tonight it's like I got punched
in the head couple years ago I had a
comic who got hit beat up at a club and
when I saw him his head was jaded the
guy decked him probably the skull went
this way he's all [__] up now what are
you gonna do anyway what's going on with
you Lee what you got week that's the
most important thing what's going on in
your world of Comedy I told you about my
world I got nothing going on I'm good
man I have a show on Friday I'm hosting
I the next two weeks I'm hosting uh at
least once a week uh and the show is in
Turner Falls Massachusetts at a brewery
it's gonna be a lot ofun the week during
the week is open
mics well Halloween is canceling huh I'm
I'm sorry go ahead no you gotta remember
Lee I love you to De you're doing four
to five sets a week during the week
that's big don't ever trip on yourself
if you don't have Friday and Saturday
work in time you'll start getting guess
sets in time when people come to town
they're gonna go call Lee I just saw I'm
in Milwaukee let them come down here and
do and you just go down there you're not
expecting no money you go down there you
work your magic you work behind a
different host maybe the guy's a [__]
balloon act you learn how to follow a
[__] balloon act I don't know but
that's how you really get in the mix but
right now you're doing the best thing in
the world four to five sets a week that
put you at 20 for the month if you do
that and you take the weekends off and
play the violin I don't give a [__] I'm
trying and I'll have to look back and
see what I'm averaging but I'm
trying uh I'm trying to do as much as I
can so it's pretty you're going for 300
a year at this
level at least you're going for 25 spots
a month right now you've been doing
comedy for three or four years right now
you're going now all of those paid if
you have 25 in a month if you start
getting five five that's your
goal then for two months in a row you
get seven then the next month you go up
to eight and a half some guy gives you a
steak for dinner if you do the open mon
you know it's just leing it and it goes
on and so forth and next thing you know
you go from doing three spots a week at
open mics to uh four or five to doing
three and four at a club now you're
doing seven spots and four of them in
front of a real audience and you build
until the final goal is to be on stage
every night in Los Angeles so you get 10
years from now or eight years from now
[__] The World is Yours you've
already gone through this basic
training and that's like it's crazy to
think about but that's like it's
honestly all I think about and it's
um it's hard it it was I was kind of
down on myself honestly for like the
last week or so I felt I I was like very
upset and because like there's it's been
a trend of if I'm in front of like a
Booker or someone like that it's not I
don't usually do as well as I I normally
do no because you get nervous so I
rather you take yourself away from the
booker go in there but now you're just
telling me jokes in The Green Room like
you used to take your mind there it's
funny when the book came out I read it
immediately even though I did the audio
on it right and then last
week my wife wanted me to sign it
somebody she one of her neighbors said
can you sign and I picked it up to sign
it and it opened up to like a chapter
and it was standup
comedy you know and it
was that time you know I forget now
because I ate those [__] edibles but
it was pretty inspiring to me I read
like five or six pages and I got the
tingles because I knew how special that
time was now at that time I was making
$99,000 a year [__] but that's how
special that time was to me there was so
much action going on I was part of a
community of comics I was part of a club
in Seattle I was hanging with Josh Wolf
I was living with Josh Wolf it was you
know even though I was starving to make
ends meet it was a time that you can't
replace it was a perfect launching for
me to go to LA and it talks a lot about
Doug Stan hope helping me out calling
the store for me and you know it just
brought me back and next thing know I'm
doing five nights a week at the [__]
store
Le and I'm dying four out of the five
I'm dying Saturday in the main room I'm
dying Thursday in the original room
Wednesday I'm doing all right you know
all right and then I have two nights
where I get lucky and I have good sets
you know it's it's it's just it's a
rotation don't get down on yourself even
though you are I did you know I did
you're gonna but the thing about comedy
the thing about we it teaches you to
break down is comedy is a day-to-day War
it's like those kids that went to
Vietnam you going to Vietnam for 10
years and your war is to get better and
it's dayto day you know I was a junkie
so I know what it's like to get up in
the morning drink whatever's there and
all already think about how am I going
to get 25 bucks today to [__] score a
bag but now you have to take that and
put it to Comedy so I would wake up in
the morning and that's the first thing I
would call everybody what's going on
tonight because you don't know some guy
would say I got a fraternity in Fort
Collins do you mind if I give you a ride
and do 10 minutes
no that was part of the
addiction that was addiction that I had
to have something by 12 or I was just
[__] hijacking a show I was going to
an open mic a poetry reading I was going
to you know whatever provided eight
minutes I was [__] hooked the same
way I was on blood you know we were
having a conversation the other day on
the phone
about how it gets to a point where you
don't want to be anywhere else but doing
comedy right and that's a very hard
thing to tell people especially when you
have a relationship
and they look at you and go what' you
just say and you're like
listen you got a nice house you know
your [__] smells like flowers but I'd
much
rather I'd much rather be in a dingy bar
in the
back with a bunch of guys that are
looking for a [__]
Dream It's a pretty interesting concept
when you think about it and everybody in
that room has their own little dream
whether you agree age with them or not
right who don't even have a dream they
just show up every [__]
Tuesday and here you are worrying about
all this stuff just show up any Comics
just show [__]
up keep showing
up you were talking about being part of
like a a community and I was thinking
about something today and it's something
that I don't do well enough and I
don't I don't spend enough time just
hanging out
after and and I I see that it it's
something that like I I think is
important like how like how much would
you hang out in those
days every
night every night when I was doing open
mics in the city it was tough nobody
wants you creeping around like a spider
you just [__] died on my died you
know God the piano player was here to
save the [__] walls from collapsing
you know they don't want you hanging out
so so you if you like you did you get
one of your comedy buddies who bombed
with you you go get a slice of pizza and
you try to meet up tomorrow write a joke
maybe take an acting class maybe go to a
free right comedy workshop at NYU you
know there's so many things we were
talking about comedy work comedy work is
not just [__] getting on stage guys
not just getting on stage the first five
years you're doing
everything in the next couple years
you're going to BU been to people
everybody's a [__] I'm a producer no
you're not you're M Lavar okay you know
who's a producer this guy because he
done comedy he's ate his [__] he figured
out he's not a good comedian but he's a
good
promoter he's rooms he knows where he
stands and you know it's it's a it's a
beautiful [__] thing man I'm so happy
for you Lee in so many ways it makes me
uh you know I see the [__] Beauty I
remember some of the the beauty not that
I ever want to [__] do it again but
it was a very very
fun I I appreciate when you call me at
night and go I went to an open mic there
was a guy in the back that was yelling
two weeks ago you went when there was a
[__] on stage you know there's always
something going on and that's the world
of an open mic it also tries to test
your will for you to go why am I down
here this guy's missing a leg I got a
guy up there with I got another guy
playing the Bongos talking about he
hates Jamaicans you know but that's what
builds up so when you get to a higher
level nothing could [__] phase
you that's definitely true you can light
yourself on fire if I'm killing you're
gonna die before I you
know Jes until you burn to death or you
laugh to death I I don't [__] know
but it's such a you
know I don't watch that much stand up
anymore
no no it's kind of weird
but it's uh it's great to
see like Ari like I talk to Ari a lot
you know that's my dog I talk to I the
buy sickler Simone we always talk about
comedy you know and it's like I feel
good now because I could talk to you
people I'm like semi-retired but I can
consult and you guys know I won't take
it down a dark path because I've done it
all so I know what I'm pretty much
talking about or at least I'm pretty
[__] close when it comes to
standup you know we weren't one of
Hollywood's pretty boys we just didn't
walk up there and people love me right
away I had to worked for every inch and
that's why it tastes so much better
today
[__] so I gotta tell you this Lee
you're GNA love it okay so
Saturday
I had to go to shop
right all
right my wife wanted me to get like
ent's breakfast stuff like maybe a
Danish they were gonna go to church or
something like that so you about that
[__] go down there I walked in I went to
the wrong area like I did last time she
didn't tell me till I got home that an's
got two places and at shop right so I
only went to the one place and I got to
be honest with you I was kind of high
when I went in there and I don't know I
looked at the ent's donuts and [__] like
that she wanted a [__] cake to bring
to church where they all sit around and
Cut the Cake not that she should I'm
just going to leave but you got to show
up with something right so I went down
there and I didn't find it I called her
up and she goes just come home I'll go
over there says I'm walking out some kid
goes Uncle Joey Uncle Joey and I go yeah
what's up he goes can I take a picture
of you come on walk me to the car he get
you know I give him a [__] number now
when I get him the number I can see he's
a little stunned he takes the picture
and I got the whistle in my pocket right
so
he he takes the picture he goes Uncle
Joey I gotta talk to you about something
I grew up on the church I listened to it
in the in high school he goes I gotta
ask you something I'm 24 but there's a
girl that wants to date me and she's 42
she's [__] hot but I don't know I'm
kind of scared I go what are you scared
of and she goes well I've always dated
uh you know girls my age I don't know
what to do what would you do I'm
embarrassed to ask my dad I go listen
bro 42 and she divorced he goes yeah the
kids like [__] 10 but she goes away
to the father's on the weekend and she
wants me to hook up with her I go have
you shown up yet he goes no I'm kind of
scared I don't know what direction to go
I go listen I go what nationality is he
I go she's she's Italian and she's hot I
go listen you go over there and you grab
those diabetic
ankles you flip her on her back you rip
those panties off you get that panty
liner you sniff the drippings and you on
her [__] you never sniff the
drippings of a p I've never I've never
picked up a panty liner you sniff the
drippings then you blow your nose in it
then you [__] throw it up in the
aedge say
whippy and then you eat that monkey they
go [__] Banas they don't know what to
do he just looked at me and I blew the
whistle at him he [__] mummified poor
bastard never heard language like that
just like he's never heard of a panty
liner yeah he just looked at me I a rip
that py liner out of there and you sniff
the
drippings and then you dig into that
monkey like a man out of prison you
understand me he just looked at
me what was he did you ever hook up with
someone like that 10 years older than
you
when I was 19 or 18 I had a 28 year old
girlfriend but she didn't have a panty
she didn't even have
panties Jesus you wore panties like once
in a
while how did you meet her she was
cutting my
hair to be honest she was my neighbor I
just moved to Colorado and her and her
sister live next door and they'd always
come over and hang with us and cook and
share food I was young that girl yeah I
was young and stupid so I would go over
there and try to hit on her and one day
I just asked her the truth and she goes
when you move out we could hook up
because I don't want to sleep with my
neighbor I go bang don't worry I wasn't
out that [__] apartment two hours I
was already in front of a house with a
[__] tuxedo on a dozen
roses and she came back to my house with
[__] Bree cheese and an apple I had
never eaten Bree cheese before and
crackers and [__] and she had AET she
wanted to sit in the middle and I'm like
listen I'm 18 years old I just want to
eat your [__] I just want to get to
tune you up and she's like n you got to
eat some apples and B and we laid out
there for like four [__] hours and
I'm a kid I'm like I just want to do
what I got to do here I don't want to
lay out here and talk about [__] you
know imp
possible I can't imagine you doing what
would you tell your 18-year-old self now
if if he if he was telling you that what
that you ate bre and apples like you
wouldn't eat Bri and apples now I love
breed cheese now really anytime I go
like I won't buy it for the house but if
I go to an event and they got a circle
of breed cheese that [__] is
going to go I eat half of it and I wrap
the rest up and put it in my pocket I
like that breed cheese I eat one piece
on an Apple just to feel like a [__]
boy scoutt but that [__] goes on a piece
of cracker or a nice piece of Italian
bread that's crispy a little Bree cheese
a piece of pruit that [__]
there's a place around here that makes a
turkey sandwich with breed
cheese damn and it's pretty I only had
it one time but it's part of a a
sandwich it comes a certain way like
with mustard and stuff my friend gave me
half in one of the girls softball games
you know what I'm saying nice have you
ever done that have you ever taken food
from like a buffet or something I've
wanted to yeah when I was a kid you know
when you 16 we used to go to the mic
and try to put a bunch of shrimp in a
napkin and put it in your sleeve and
your jacket and then hopefully you make
it out of there not the napkin Falls all
the shrimp Falls he's walking straight
something happened once at one of those
restaurants where my friend dropped a
napkin with something in their wings or
and it landed right in the middle and
everybody looked at it yeah this is 40
years ago I mean it's not like people at
home remember we in the restaurant that
chubby kid n they don't remember this
[__] but we were young and we went
somewhere one of my buddies tried to be
cute and you get you know the Chinese
napkins they're big and they like if you
put them he was clipping them and then
he put them all in there before we left
so the grease wouldn't go through it
damn [__] yeah so did you guys get
kicked out or something no we just
walked out it wasn't me dog I'm not into
stealing [__] nework [__] shrimp
I'm not going to go to jail for [__]
shrimp with the black still in the back
you know it's that shrimp that you dip
yeah in the [__] 80s when you gave
away shrimp everybody came out you know
everybody tried to get over on shrimp I
still remember people going to me bro I
go there just to eat the shrimp and I
look at them like you know I get it now
I just go to a buffet and get the
goodies but back then go to get the
shrimp and they didn't give a [__] where
it came from that shit'll kill you out
one of these happy hours you got to be
careful where you eating that shrimp
from they keep saying they have it in
Vegas like cheap shrimp cocktails and
I've never seen it like I've never seen
like a 99 cent shrimp cocktail they got
them they got everything in Vegas but
it's not the shrimp I almost died on
when I went to that restaurant where you
that big [__] prawn it's GNA be one
of those leftover Katrina shrimp that's
been in the warehouse since the [__]
storm and they just busted it out
because it snuck through FDA approval
whatever the [__] it is the fish people
let it pass and now listen what you know
I mean if I give you a 99 cents what am
I attracting I'm taking a loser deal so
I got to give you a shrimp that's three
or four days
old I go to Vegas I see a $99 a 99 cent
steak and
eggs you gotta ask yourself what kind of
meat is
that is this a price leader am I going
to go in there and buy this and do they
want me to buy green chili like when we
go to Sams you buy the two eggs and if
you pay an extra 50 cents they throw the
green chili in and you know so I've
always been suspect of that of that
Mafia meat that it's cheap and what I
heard they did because I heard that this
is what I read year 30 years ago guys I
read this when I lived in
Bowen Paul castalano was a
butcher okay okay and when he became
boss of the gambinos or a little before
that he devised a
scan where the meat that gets old on a
when you go to a when you go to a I
don't want to name a supermarket because
you know when you go to a super market
and 9:30 and it closes at 10: and they
have like you go to the Stak section
they have like three Stakes that have
been there all day and you look at the
expiration and they've been out there
since
yesterday Paul castalano wouldn't just
throw that away he'd take that meat and
he' dip it in a chemical it was a that
they had and it made the meat look fresh
again and they take that meet to Vegas
and that's the 99 State and then it said
it goes the chemical would get you a
little sick like a little bit of
diarrhea like you'd wake up in the
middle of night and you fart and a
little bit of diarrhea but not enough to
make you go crazy you wouldn't [__]
[__] blood for out
so I I had that happen before like right
like two years ago I went to one of
those all you can like exclusive or
whatever all inclusive resorts in Mexico
and was we left early it was that bad
sure you did sure you did the steak was
we to we couldn't eat one bite of
it I remember being maybe I don't know a
young comic and going and dog you starve
as a comic so when you go to these
casinos the first time and you're a
feature they give you like an employee
card that means you're eating the
employee food that's a piece of chicken
with a bite taken out of it but took off
the buffet bit it and put it back no I'm
teasing you but you know listen man when
you're broke and you're getting $600 for
the week and you have to pay for your
plane ticket out of
that you pretty much eat what they give
you you know you go to do a one nighter
in a bar they're paying you 500 bucks to
do some [__] bar you think they got
steaks in there they got onion rings and
a [__] typical
burger you know and what are you gonna
eat you got $4 in your pocket and
they're gonna pay you with a check what
are you gonna
eat what they give you with dinner
well are you GNA eat a [__] salmon at
a bar with a the bartender's got herpes
on the neck no I don't think so you know
you're not g to get a [__] salmon
dinner there but you look around and you
see where you're at and you gotta watch
it can you imagine get doing a gig and
getting paid and you eat at some [__]
joint and you get stomach sick I've
worked with a couple Comics that
happened in 30 years maybe two times it
happened [__] I went with a comic one
time when I was an open micer I was in
the crossover
during his show he kept saying can the
host come up
here I gotta give you the host no I was
the feature this is one of the B Bower
gigs okay I know face but I don't
remember his name and he [__] went to
the bathroom to puke he had eaten
something at the [__] bar and now he
couldn't show so me and the [__] host
had finish the show I mean he got his
money I didn't give a [__] I got stay
more stage time more time to bomb so all
work
out have that I remember like
specifically I forget I forget when it
was it was years ago that you did The
Improv One Night in Hollywood and you
were like really sick like you had a
cold and we were you were standing out
in the rain I was like Jesus Christ like
have you ever like been traveling and
gotten like sick enough to not do a show
or do you just power through it you
power through it if you're on the road
what are you going to call the club
owner and go you get up that morning
you're all by yourself you got got no
car you got to take a cab to like a CVS
you got to buy thlu vix Vapor Rub
whatever they got the hotel you're going
to be in a hotel that the people don't
speak English when you go downstairs and
ask them for aspirin they're G to give
you a [__] baking soda thinking
you're making cracks so you know you
just got to work it dog I had a horrible
experience in 2015 I woke up with
vertigo in Chicago oh [__] and I had two
shows on a Saturday night and I'll never
forget getting up in the middle of night
to pee and just falling on the floor and
the room and the whole day I had to sit
in the [__] bed thank God the hotel
had room service I had a crawl to get
the [__] room
service I don't know if I knew that yeah
and I did two shows with my head twisted
while the whole room was just going bang
bang bang bang bang and the next morning
I was a little better when I got on the
plane and then I got home and I had to
get my ears checked out and I had
something going on with my ear
and I had a remember for a while I had
to wear something I no I remember you
had vertigo but I don't remember you
crawling on the floor to get room
service anyway because you weren't
there how would you you might I don't
know you told me a lot of [__] about
yourself sure but who the [__] was there
there was nobody else there there was
somebody there You' think I'd be
crawling to [__] get the [__] food
no I know I wasn't in the room but you
know [__] I [__] St my toe I tell you
about it so you performing at this week
my brother it's a place in uh in Western
Massachusetts it's a brewery
called
sorry uh next week I'm at silvertone Bor
and Grill in Boston and Brook and
feather brewing and uh Turner Falls Mass
and this is Friday and Saturday Friday
this week Saturday next week okay well
I'm really proud of you man had a good
time with you tonight even though we're
both [__] pretty high but we got to
get higher we got to blow one out of the
[__] water you know what I'm saying
let's do it I love doing this buddy it's
always good to see you me too it's good
to see you Joe stay
[Music]
black the checkin is brought to you by
freeze pipe happy Halloween listen stop
looking like a [__] when you're getting
stoned all right if you're tired of
breathing in L smoke and then coughing
up a half a lung you got to try freeze
pipe it's an awesome device that cools
down the Smoke by over 300 degrees so
you can take icy cool hits all night
long like a doctor you pop the glycerin
chamber in the freezer for an hour to
get started hour and a half as the smoke
passes through the chamber bam it's
cooled off no afterburn no coughin I
love it I made a video yesterday on
Instagram with the new freeze pipe I
busted out I had the other one for like
two years but it was time to go bigger
so listen check out their newest pieces
the mini bang and the tornado bong I
really love it it's a tight little buong
you can hide it under your car it's an
awesome way to get an icy cold hit every
time let me break it down for you this
company's American-owned for seven years
and affordably priced shop the smoothest
and coolest pipe bubblers bongs at more
the free pipe.com use code Diaz Diaz for
10% off your entire order that's freees
pipe.com code Diaz for 10% of your
entire order remember one thing this
makes a great Christmas present trust me
what I'm telling you even Grandma I love
it the checkin is also brought to you by
Blue chew it's Halloween it's a
beautiful night to sling dick with your
little [__] crazy outfit on you're
going to have an incredible evening
tonight but don't ruin it with crappy
sex blue chw is here to make sure things
stay up and up you know what I'm saying
even if you have a wolf man suit on it's
tied around the waist blue Chu is an
online service that delivers Ed meds
straight to your door with the same
active ingredients as Viagra
Calis Levitra and you're getting all the
fun at a fraction of the cost all right
just sign up at bl.com consult with one
of their me medical providers and once
you're approved bam you get the
prescription in just a few days it's
totally online so nobody knows nothing
you don't have to go to some doctor's
office and they look at you like a
vampire and you don't got to think like
your dick is broken hide behind the veil
of the internet and perk things up from
the comfort of your couch listen this is
the real deal you pop one of these blue
shoes like 30 minutes before you want to
get down forget about it you'll be
sniffing a little panty liner you follow
me blue Chu wants to help you have
better sex discover your options at
blue.com chew it and do it Jack and as a
special deal for the check and listeners
try blueo free what are you talking
about Joey free when you use promo code
Joey at checkout just pay $5 for
shipping that's blu.com promo code Joey
to receive your first month free
visit blu.com for more details